gracias amigos del menudo all los arcos
the Oscars El Chico door Johnny question
tienes mas macho Mel Gibson T Benicio
del Toro Mel Gibson no Benicio del Toro
s mas macho Mel Gibson a smart religious
it was fun to do
ladies and gentlemen this is the reason
for a five-second delay stop it what are
you doing you can't do that
stop it it's a five-second delay yes
look at us the San Francisco wedding
cake
best man I hope so brow would you give
the award yes I will go or today Logie
award now thank you
I'm here tonight to present the Award
for Best Animated Feature one of them is
made by the French one by Disney one by
Pixar formerly of Disney makes you think
of a French Minnie Mouse with armpit
hair smoking a cigarette going
what are you doing Michael eyes now
listen if you lose Miramax all you're
gonna have left is basically a muppet
and a water slide crazy for Mia and you
Americans with your freedom fries ha ha
they're from Belgium actually now I
would like to announce the nominees for
Best Feature animation the nominees stay
Brother Bear Ellen Page and Robert
Walker Finding Nemo and who's that
The Triplets of Belleville Silvan show
me the winner of best animated feature
film to date and the Oscar goes to
Finding Nemo understand this is the
first Academy Award for Andrew Stanton
and third nomination
he's also nominated tonight in the
Original Screenplay category for finding
Nemo Finding Nemo would have never been
possible if it wasn't for the
extraordinary filmmaking environment
created at Pixar Animation Studios by
John Lasseter Ed Catmull and Steve Jobs
and I am I'm going to be forever
grateful to the entire cast and crew of
Nemo for the giving of their
incomparable talents to this little fish
story that I had in particular my
producer Graham Walters and my
co-director Lee Unkrich who should be up
here with me right now accepting this
thanks to a dick cook and his incredible
distribution team at Disney thanks to
the Academy to my loving parents to my
adoring children and to my wife Julie I
wrote it to you in a note in eighth
grade and now I can say it in front of a
billion people I love you
coming up then is our group Nicolas Cage
and two-time Oscar winner Tom Hanks